welcome back to new rockstars robert
pattinson as the batman is facing
a serial killing riddler whose
motive we're starting to get a clearer
picture of but
like any great noir film there's always
some greater conspiracy on the other end
of the
unraveled duct tape we're gonna crack
that code
cause this is road theory the podcast
set brings you the wildest nerdy hot
takes on the topics you can't stop
arguing about i'm eric voss
with me today two [ __ ] rogue theories
our friends from the real rejects
youtube channel
greg alba and john humphrey hey guys
welcome back back
we're back we're so happy to be here
we're not
exhausted at all you guys were the first
out there with that great reaction video
and uh we actually experimented with
doing a reaction video we rarely do them
but like i was watching years i'm like
oh i got to be more animated when i do
that these guys are great it's so much
fun to watch you guys watch stuff
we loved yours we loved yours yours is
the best everything you do is the best
is this oh let's do another 10 minutes
of just complimenting each other
we can't do that because we have another
guest with us first time here on new
rockstars comedian writer and producer
and a friend of mine from our time doing
improv together at the upright citizens
brigade in los angeles
shukri abdi welcome oh
really happy to be here i i've watched
watchmen
a couple of years all right hell yeah
okay i'm so glad we could get you on new
rockstars for anyone watching yeah sugar
and i used to do stuff at ucb and i
looked back on that team
a crazy amount of who's whose were on
that team and moses storm
didn't improv with us on that team uh
katie maravich from collegehumor was on
that team
who's a super special development yeah
[Music]
we got to meet sia sia came to see our
final show like
it was like a star-studded summer and
then i got
on no other used to be teams after that
but here's the good news they're closed
so
it might not ever reopen hopefully
hopefully all right let's dive into the
batman matt reeves the batman is
reintroducing the caped crusader as a
year two batman played of course by
robert pattinson
whose attempts to reign in crime in
gotham city have backfired now we got
paul dano
as a murderous riddler leaving behind
zodiac style clues
the first of which we were able to solve
in our trailer breakdown be sure to go
watch that but there's gonna be a lot of
other clues
uh especially ones in this trailer that
point to like this big political
conspiracy subplot
one that has us wondering who the real
big bad of the story could be
because it's never just the psycho
killer on the ground in the trenches
there's always someone behind that who
is uh either the cause of
or the recipient of that who's gonna get
exposed
and i believe this true villain is gonna
be the one that batman will have to face
in this movie sequel whoever it is
you know kind of like the way nolan's
batman begins ended with that joker
calling card that set up the dark knight
so i want to know from you three who do
you think is really pulling the strings
of this mystery who is the real
ultimate threat of the story that batman
might have to face in the sequel
greg why don't you go first okay or we
could all go at the same exact time
all right well let me start with this uh
i think we've got a lot of characters
being reintroduced into the batman story
and i think in this version which i
believe is year two of bruce wayne being
batman they're reestablishing the world
of gotham so you're gonna have famous
rogue gallery characters like penguin
catwoman and riddler i think penguin at
this point is far from being the
criminal kingpin
he desires to be at this current stage
he's just a ruthless but envious man and
i think he works for carmine falcone and
wishes to surpass him
but carmine also works for someone else
who
i wonder this might segue into my thing
selena kyle
um i don't think she'll be a full-on
villain perhaps someone who occasionally
rides the line of
thief and semi-robin hood she looks out
for her neighborhood and those that she
cares about that she grew up with but
i don't think she mind stealing from the
big bad gangsters or the corrupt
politicians as
established in this trailer but uh in
between that there's someone whose
actions are creating streets
in gotham and i think that's why celina
kyle will team up with batman eventually
and that is the riddler so while the
other two criminals are on the surface
riddler is obsessed with the evil
underneath the surface
he has a line in this trailer that says
if you are justice please do not lie
and i think riddler now being named
edward nash in this movie sees himself
in batman
he doesn't see himself as a criminal but
as a hero someone who can
lead batman to uncover the truth the
truth about
that the politicians and those who are
supposed to protect us
really work for someone else but also
that the leaders in this organized crime
syndicates
they answer to the same exact people
batman as stated by alfred in this
trailer is becoming a bit of a celebrity
the media is loving him it's becoming
known he's helping the cops to take down
the criminals in gotham but
riddler he's an obsessed individual and
hates knowing the truth
but watching the world ruled by lies he
sees that in order for
real change to happen batman can't be
taking down the criminals on the surface
but the corrupt and powerful that lurks
in the shadows
which is obviously the court of owls
yes yes okay matson tomlin the writer of
the film he talked about how this film
will explore the soul of batman and
bruce wayne
but what does this storyline have to do
with bruce wayne i think at this point
in the story the court of owls are
considered a myth
a legend passed down in nursery rhymes
to scare children into behaving good
right and so we'll learn at one point
that bruce thought his parents was
associated with
uh the court their death was associated
with the court of owls but couldn't find
any evidence on their actual existence
and that's where edward comes in he's a
man who's crafted an identity of riddles
obviously he also grew up in gotham was
obsessed with the nursery rhymes but was
able to decode that they actually exist
but why so i think riddler will sort of
be like a cross between kevin spacey and
seven
and robin williams and insomnia and he
knows who batman really is he knows he's
bruce wayne
and that's why he really wants to use
him because after batman finally
captures riddler
he reveals that the court of owls had
involvements with the waynes
as explored in the new 52 and gotham
series and that the answer
to thomas and martha wayne's murders
lies in the quote-unquote conspiracy
of the owls segwaying in to part
two i'm done i'm finally done oh i love
it
yeah greg i definitely think you're on
to something i mean we saw in that uh
riddler gift card that crazy ass
halloween card that i know halloween
cards exist but like
candy please like i don't want a
freaking card um
with the crate he must have custom
printed that and uh he's got to be
putting clues on there with the owl
on there um and yeah this is the one of
the more interesting batman villains to
come out of the new 52 that has never
been explored in film
and you could tell that dc definitely
recognizes the value here by putting
them
in gotham knights as like this
villainous threat in the game
do you see court of alice is kind of the
the specter of this you know like uh
james bond the university of specter
that keeps going back again and again
and again
or is it like um a smaller tribal
council that can be taken down
but then there's some other kind of
threat beyond oh no 100 percent they're
going to be like spectre they're
they they have had their their their
claws planted in hot talon a
quarterback's reference they've had
their claws you know planted inside of
gotham's roots for
for centuries at this point so yeah
they're gonna be
certainly the specter of the gotham
world that is in here
greg i'm going to award you with uh two
sparkle bucks hell yeah oh boy
one or two what do those turn into on
your end oh grab them grab them grab
them
they they turn into this
this ridge wallet oh wow
with a new rockstars promo code to get
10 off
code real rejects whichever one works i
was about to ask where you could get a
ridge wallet
well i would go through new rockstars as
well on their channel now
that's probably better i
they are not a sponsor of this episode
but hey if they happen to come up we
can't control it
here we don't edit anything in this
episode
get that edit away get that out of the
way he's trying to edit things in
there's no post-production
allowed uh all right uh shukri what do
you think is gonna be
the the deeper mystery to the riddler in
this story all right
so paul dano from 2014's love and mercy
the film about the beach boys
yeah paul danno is
bruce wayne's friend oh yeah okay
he is dr thomas elliott who's a doctor
who is helping out
batman and batman hits his head and he
has a concussion etc etc but
dr thomas elliott helps him out he goes
off why does the riddler have a problem
with batman
bruce's parents were pieces of [ __ ]
because have you become that rich
without having your hand in some in some
muck you know what i'm saying
so dr thomas elliott has an axe to grind
with
bruce's parents because his parents
were whistleblowers on [ __ ] ass bruce's
uh parents
so whoa yes yes i know this is very
convoluted please try to keep up with me
what did bruce's parents do what did
they do what what
needed what whistle needed to be blown
on them what is jeff bezos guilty of
i mean do we have to come up with a
specific or can we just say that rich
people you know eat them
and chuck them like you can't you can't
get to the top and have that much
without [ __ ] on
a whole slew of the popularity that's
right every billionaire is a policy
failure yes
i mean we could go down the laundry list
they they
they weren't taxed the rich weren't
taxed look turn on mms anything
13 not 13. nbc shirts
i'm not turning on those guys because
they'll turn back on you hard
so i got whistle was blown parents were
duct taped by the mafia
hidden underground flood flood flood
floods
so they were drowned with duct tape so
that's
you're working in the duct tape that's
why he uses duct tape to duct tape all
of his people yeah
i can only present the facts
i i'm glad that you're jumping along
with me from fact to fact but that's
what it is and so
that's how we get the riddler's origin
story because he's like oh you want to
duct tape my mom and my dad
well rate that's me too
shoot great uh some very interesting
ideas you just brought up i love this
idea of working in
uh the duct tape into his origin story
because the fact that the trailer opened
with the sound of duct tape the fact
that not only does he wrap his victim's
head
with duct tape where's the mask of duct
tape himself it looks like it looks like
that thing
he looks like you know that year in high
school where we all are like oh i could
just
make a backpack out of duct tape i can
make a prom suit out of duct tape and
everyone's like
i'm not going to dance with them shukri
i i do love this idea of using hush
because it seems like
uh edward nation in this movie is taking
inspiration from hush
uh the fact that the whole bandaging up
of the face um
the fact that riddler is involved with
it uh and hush is such a fascinating
mystery
that does involve many characters of the
rogue's gallery as this movie appears to
be doing
so uh for for trying to find a way to
get
hush into this story and to get back to
bruce wayne's childhood and the
childhood friend that gets under his
skin
i'm awarding you two
sparkle bugs on the board
and what do they transform into on your
end they transform into
a dvd of lars and the real girl that's a
great moment
that is a good movie is she real
no i think she's real in here
that makes it a vintage thing right you
found a blockbuster i used to walk to
blockbuster every friday by myself when
i was single and it was my little date
with myself
oh and now blockbuster left you
there's one more blockbuster
you can still get him run to the airport
that's right get there get there
all right uh john what do you think is
going to be the real deeper mystery
behind the riddler in this batman movie
all right step aside kids because my
theory includes kind of everyone's
theory because i know what matt reeves
is doing all right he's setting up a
trilogy and as much as he wants to talk
about how this movie's gonna test bruce
wayne's soul
i'm focused on gotham all right and you
know what
much like christopher nolan chose three
themes for his dark knight trilogy i
think matt reeves gonna do the same
thing and this first movie is all going
to be about the body
of gotham figuring out what the true
nature is
what the city's politics really are what
the power structures really are
it looks like as we pointed out in the
trailer riddler he also wants to
expose the true corruption that maybe
batman doesn't see or is biased towards
because of his family
as we've talked about perhaps they had
some kind of involvement
with the court of owls and in my version
we're going to go down a rabbit hole
that shows that they were
members of the court of owls
of the father and mother too
and so through this mystery we will
realize that they are still
grappling for control in gotham but we
also have the mob
we have the police in the state that
they are in and i feel like
what we are building to with this movie
is yeah there will be a presence of the
court of owls but they are just one
among many players the riddler is back
to him because he is involved his
ultimate goal
is to reveal the past batman's hypocrisy
given his roots
um and the fact that they have a similar
motive by the look of things you know
truly exposing the corruption of gotham
and so through this adventure riddler is
driven
further mad and towards the film's
conclusion it's revealed that he
too has been a pawn in the scheme of
someone who's been feeding secrets into
his ear feeding misinformations perhaps
a doctor maybe a psychologist or a
psychiatrist perhaps
hugo strange
as we're setting up the sequel i mean
gcpd is in a shambles
the second movie is going to be a battle
for the mind
of gotham and who better than the person
who
deduced batman's identity early on who
is a master of the mind but is mad
himself think of a sequel we've got this
guy with a hand in arkham
in indian hill we've got this guy with a
hand among the court of owls
and with gotham i mean in the sequel i
mean there's gonna be
this is a three movie arc where gordon's
gonna be commissioner by part three all
right the police are a mess in part two
cordovals they're not fully back yet but
they want their old grip
restored and then you got the mob who's
the mob so yeah in the trilogy
body mind and soul we're setting up soul
chapter yeah seoul's part three the song
gotham will be part three but yeah
the mind the madness that's what we're
setting up for with part two
and hugo strange nice i love it
that was good uh and in my moment i'm so
sorry to cut you off senpai erica
here's how we tease him somebody wanders
out of a shadow we think everything's
fine for now
it's one of the thugs but he looks kind
of jacked up and nasty
and all he utters is one phrase
bruce wayne given to him
by his creator hugo strange
god oh god
by his collaborator on his outcome
god and he destroys cool
that was very nice uh well done john um
you got a little clap of joy out of me
um yeah i think it's very interesting
hugo strange is up there with a quarter
court of owls for me is
one like a fascinating character i i
want
to go into arkham asylum i want one of
these movies to be an adaptation of the
arkham games in some way
and you don't do that without hugo
strange like the you know
the nurse ratchet of that asylum
and uh i'm i'm very curious which eric
the film that the second movie is going
to borrow from is one flew over the
cuckoo's nest
yeah oh someone says chinatown and then
there you go that's right it's
the
fascinating ideas there you're gonna get
uh three
sparkle bucks for that
my goodness that's so impressive i got a
bottle of hand sanitizer
uh a tattered deck of cards
and oh would you have that another ridge
wallet
oh wow man where do people get getting
those because they are
not cheap are worth the money
worth every 100 of them
uh well some very great thoughts here
we're going to continue talking about
the batman
obviously because it's um news it's
actual news
that we can talk about uh here on our
nerdy channels
so uh continue to follow uh subscribe
all that all that [ __ ] uh but before
we continue we wanna thank some people
who helped us
make this episode first we want to thank
our friends at
shipstation if you're an e-commerce
seller right now is a
wild time and shipstation is here to
help you
see when new rockstars has tried to ship
things in the past it was confusing
figuring out the logistics and the costs
of everything is uh the postal service
in existence anymore well shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping and keep customers happy
they get you the shipping rates normally
reserved for fortune 500 companies
not anymore now the little guys are
getting it too we're all going to be
shipping things at the same rates uh
it's the fastest it's the easiest most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just a few clicks
and you'll be managing your orders
getting your product to happy customers
shipstation works with all the major
carriers and their interface brings your
products together whether you're selling
them on etsy amazon or
your own website shipstation is the
number one choice for
online sellers you'll ship more and less
time with the best rates available and
right now you can try shipstation for
free for 60 days when you use the offer
code
rogue make sure your business is ready
to meet the demands of delivery culture
get started at shipstation.com today
click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
rogue
and that's shipstation.com then enter
the offer code rogueshipstation.com
make ship happen all right we also want
to thank our friends at
hydrant for helping us make this episode
we all know that we should drink more
water but by the time you feel thirsty
it's too late you're dead you're a
corpse you're in the ground no one's
mourning you
you're already dehydrated it's a point
folks is
uh folks is you can't focus this is
do you feel tired this is i need to take
this right now
because hydrant has created a refreshing
electrolyte
powder that you mix into the water to
hydrate you quickly and keep you going
longer forever each rapid hydration mix
has the four essential electrolytes your
body needs and it packs a bunch
to help your body hydrate fast and stay
that way
and hydrant is backed by research not
that weird
you know back alley crap that you get
that's gonna poison you and give you
weird
viruses that weren't even on the cdc's
radar
this is this is totally legit safe great
stuff
like the formula was developed by an
oxford scientist it's
loved by pro athletes has thousands of
five star reviews
this stuff's a real deal it was made
with real fruit juice powder and comes
in a variety of delicious flavors
including summer friendly flavors like
iced tea lemonade
fruit punch uh you could just like
mix it with um with any kind of other
alcohol you want to
if you do want to feel drunk but that
alcohol is going to dehydrate you if you
just want
to be hydrated just just do what they
say hydrant is backed by a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you don't love
it you can send it back for full refund
but you're going to
love it you're going to worship it we've
got a special deal for our listeners who
saves 25
off your first order go to drink
hydrogen.com rockstars or enter our
promo code rockstars at checkout
that's h y d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d r a n t
dot com slash rockstars and enter promo
code rockstars for twenty five percent
off your first order trick actually dot
com slash rock stars in enterprise rock
stars to save 25 percent and we thank
them for sponsoring
and we also want to thank our friends at
lumen skin for helping us make this
there are lots of reasons we neglect our
skin
we're busy we're lazy we're stupid we're
uh alone we don't deserve to be happy
maybe we don't know what to do besides
flash water on our face and hope for the
best
or just a cry and cry and cry into our
pillows and hope that rehydrates our
skin
they're all bad ideas the truth is our
skin has needs
like a like a gentle lover that protects
us with a hug
that has been there since birth and will
be there till the day we die our skin is
our best friend and if you want it to
look good for as long as possible
you need to address those needs there's
a company that has taken all the
guesswork out of it for you
lumen lumen is on a mission to help give
men the amazing skin they deserve
because not just women men
deserve to have to spend time on
themselves through high quality expert
creative products delivered right to
your door
lumen is there for you all of their
products are formulated for men's skin
using top-notch ingredients like
charcoal
green tea extract vitamin c as we go
on we'll remember the great choice we
made to buy
lumen you did it perfect i did it uh
lumen makes it easy to find the right
skin management system for you all you
got to do is choose from different skin
concerns to address
and you pick up a simple starter pack
for free
i got one of these starter packs this is
their moisturizing
balm and i thought balm was just
something that goes on your lips
and look at this look at what is
happening here
i am so moisturized and i am
gonna be like a sponge because i've been
so dried out dehydrated i'm just gonna
soak it all up like spongebob
i'm waking up feeling better every day
using this stuff and you deserve to look
and feel
your best and here's where you start go
to loominskin.com
rogue to get a one month free trial of
everything you need to start your
skincare journey at home
that's lumenskin.com slash rogue to your
first month free lumenskin.com all right
we're going to move on to our discord
rogue theory every week we play a game
of rogue theory with our patrons on the
new rockstars discord this week we had
some amazing patrons pitch theories
about what the biggest change to the
justice league that zack snyder
is going to make with his snyder cut we
had a real fun theory from uh
coxy coxy that focused on darkseid
our winner was cortez underscore nz
their theory focused mostly on that
post-apocalyptic nightmare sequence
and then added some formal introductions
for green lantern and martian manhunter
i truly truly hope they show up in this
snyder cut even if it's just a shout out
even if it's just a reference i want to
see
i want to see green lantern you can play
too have your theory read on an episode
of rogue theory by coming to patron at
patreon.comrockstars and you can join
our discord that way
all right two three we're moving on to
our second topic
the suicide squad also at fandom we got
our first official look at james gunn's
upcoming suicide squad film
we got confirmation of the characters at
idris elba and john cena the rest of the
cast are gonna be playing this movie
looks
crazy fun i'm so excited for it and uh
we got some footage
just little bits of it some behind the
scenes stuff that i broke down
yesterday's uh trailer breakdown go go
check it out
uh i'm gonna try to answer all your big
questions there but here
i wanna know from you guys this is kind
of the big mystery that i'm still not
really sure about is
what is this mission that they're on
what are they doing
we know this movie's gonna steer hard
into that whole a-team dirty dozen
magnificent seven
kind of team-up mission sort of thing
but based on the footage based on the
details we learned from this latest
behind-the-scenes teaser
what do you guys think that the suicide
mission of james gun suicide squad will
be
and mine's called the suicide squad
steals the air cut
and they're killing the trailer park
company that recut the first movie
because they're really pissed
[Laughter]
personally i think the suicide squad is
going to see our our
anti-heroes going to south america under
the guise
of aiding in some kind of you know
military conflict or a coup or whatever
but what they start to realize along the
way
as they start to see more and more
wreckage and they run into people
displaced by
whatever is going on it seems as though
whatever is happening here isn't all
together
on the ground human it's not just
soldiers with guns it's something more
and then finally when we reach the end
when we reach this figure this warlord
they're supposed to take out
and they find what they're supposed to
retrieve it's kryptonite weaponry
because whoa spoiler wants to bring that
[ __ ] back
so that she can start stockpiling an
arsenal and experimenting and basically
yeah taking the lex luthor theory
but you know weaponizing it and
equipping future suicide squads with it
because let's face it
uh they can't get by on guns alone
yeah that's so man what an interesting
take there john i i definitely
do see that logic and you know i i think
uh bloodsport you know idris elba's
character
he you know in the comics was imprisoned
for shooting
superman with the kryptonite bullet so
like he would be
the person amanda waller would send on
that mission as a guy who's used to this
weaponizing this kind of material and
knowing how to work with it uh so john
for that theory
uh i'm gonna give you uh a rogi sparkle
book you get one you get one here
what oh oh you don't even need to get
this one i could so happy to have one i
was i
wasn't indeed don't be greedy all right
it was like
i expected nothing and oh my god it's a
great rogi too look at how great this
it's a it's a batman under armour oh
look at that thank you it paints the abs
on
and everything you already feel jacked
and wear those to work out but i don't
have to anymore you don't have to all
you gotta do is wear it and you can just
like sit around oh man
good for you good for you pay attention
you look like a body though philip
molina now
you look great now
all right shookery what do you think the
mission's gonna be guys
they're gonna be fighting a virus
okay i like that and then we're really
going to take a hard look at ourselves
and it's not even going to be corona
it's going to be a different virus guys
oh yeah
yeah that'd be too are you paying
attention fictional fictional
virus that's right fictional virus we
can't use the real thing
well to some people the coronavirus is
fictional but not us
they've tuned out by now as you've said
already yeah but
and then we're gonna we're gonna show it
who's boss
terry crews is gonna be in it yeah
as himself or as a character is he the
president in this is this idiocracy
he's gonna play the president again
awesome yes
and you know what it's going to be a
real page turner patient is this a book
the novelization yeah
and and then because you know they want
to make sure that they keep
the spirit up with the franchise
into a graphic novel this is my this is
what i think is going to happen in the
next suicide squad
i know they're still doing things in the
edit i hope they don't steal some of
these ideas
[Laughter]
james gunn if you're watching james gunn
just write me a thank you letter i'm
just looking for a little
acknowledgement oh
man and that's pretty much what you got
suicide squad
in theaters
uh shukri i gotta say you truly know the
name of the show that was a very rogue
theory
i'll give you that uh maybe a little too
rogue
but is that a thing could it be too
rogue no it's not
it's not rogue enough
could have been more rogue so the fact
that you could have gone more rogue and
he didn't you just get one
we still get one he did a pretty good
job one club she deserves four
yes and that turned into
oh it jumped through the screen it's a
marley in me
oh hell yeah you're getting so many dvds
in suicide squad yeah mm-hmm
i mean it would fit attached yeah but
yeah don't get attached
it does all right greg
greg what do you think the mission's
gonna be in suicide squad all right
so my idea is is kind of uh
a little bit of john's and not really
anything like shoe crease
all right just to say it's better and
more developed than mine well so we'll
see
we'll see you know what i noticed in
this trailer eric
a [ __ ] ton of american flag imagery and
for an off the books team like
task force x it's kind of odd that
they're being touted in front of the
great american flag
so the official plot of this movie as
per wikipedia
is amanda waller she reassembles a
suicide squad with members old and new
and sends them on a mission to liberate
south american country
but if we know amanda waller there's
always something
much more heinous she's either trying to
retrieve
or bury so when they're first sent into
this
fictional south american country which
is having a civil war
of the people and its government they'll
be tasked to go in and help
the rebel movement overthrow the
government right because this government
is a goddamn
commie threat so the mission is simple
dirty doesn't style
they have to take out some enemy
soldiers help the freedom fighters
and destroy a government official
building where its leader is being held
but why the suicide squad america hasn't
been shy in the past of kicking in doors
of other countries and putting up a
fight
well i'll tell you because in the behind
the scenes footage
it showed us wreckage of what looked
like to be a ruined
laboratory once they get in there they
discover that this
government has been conducting
experiments
pulled they took evidence and archives
and all kinds of remnants from the
battle in russia or wherever it was at
the end of sweden's justice league
to create serums and toxins bane venom
what have you kryptonite stuff to take
on
superheroes now how did waller know
about this
because the government wouldn't fund
these experiments so she had to do it
off the books
and in the one place she never thought
the government in the u.s would look
this fictional south american country
however when the scientist she hired is
captured
the president of this fictional south
american country
wants to take these experiments
weaponize them
and use them why could so many of our
heroes while they
fight for the world they clearly mainly
fight for
america james gunn's not shy of getting
political
we know what he was like when he had a
twitter before he got cancelled
temporarily
batman wonder woman and superman they're
so american
this country they've been developing
weapons to take on not just the u.s
government but
also the superheroes who so often fight
for the greatest country in the world
the god damn u.s of a and that's that's
the plot
right wow uh i feel like i should drop
my mic
oh yeah great watch that i would watch
that you stumbled upon some very
interesting the stumbled you planned you
said some interesting things there
i'm particularly interested in this idea
of bane venom that
that could be that's when we're setting
up bane in here why not hell yeah
why not why not your suicider yeah why
not
okay so uh greg you're gonna get two two
two bucks oh well with
that too i get this
giant steps by anthony robbins book
oh that's going to help out read it one
a day
365 daily lessons and self-mastery by
anthony robbins oh and he's still going
by anthony
yeah that's a classic look at his hair
too yeah
he's a job interview tony robbins it's a
retro rogue
wow i see why your theories are so good
yeah because of this this toilet reading
book right here has
really helped me out a lot today tony
robbins actually talks a lot about the
dc universe
yeah a lot of footnotes you gotta be
like super bad she's not a marvel guy he
seems no no yeah
uh all right we're going to move on to
our final round of rogue questions is
everyone ready for this
oh yeah you're ready too ready all right
question one
in the teaser footage release for the
suicide squad john cena said that his
character peacemaker
is a quote douchey captain america
how could you make something captain
america did in the mcu
more douchey he wears sweatpants and on
his
pant on his ass it says america's ass
on those sweatpants that's right
i would say anytime he has something to
say that
resonates with the people around him he
makes his breasts dance
oh he does the peck uh
chrome that's how he gets attention at
public events
as he goes click like like i like to
make a toast
[Laughter]
okay my douchey captain america moment
is uh at the end of
you know spoilers if anybody ain't seen
an end game but during the america's ass
scene
he actually pinches it and then the
other captain america wakes up and then
they have an argument about if it's gay
or not that he's admiring his own mask
when they should really just be secure
in themselves interesting
uh i do i gotta give uh shukri the point
there for the
clinkin
anytime i use those muscles now i'm
going to think of that
it turns into the movie the 10.
hey yeah these are good these are great
it's an interesting one
not his best but uh it's got some fun
moments in there
for sure all stars a lot everyone in
it's great
you can make your own suicide squad out
of all yeah yeah
our final question a trailer came out
this week for the ps5 game called lord
of the rings
gollum in honor of that can i please
hear your best gollum impression
thanking people for watching this show
yo john you'll probably have the best
one let's get the best one out of the
way
you wouldn't let me get my theories out
precious
your theories are terrible now precious
we can win the game
eric loves us precious we black hydrant
and we bought lumen and that's gollum
yeah stupid fat
rogies give me a rookie i wish to win
the rookie i'm so desperate for
attention to win the damn rookie
pretty good as well
what are you talking about what are you
talking about
oh [ __ ] you're watching
suicide squad it's so scary for me to
watch
i don't know how i watch on the toilet
oh oh my god sugri
are you okay you looked like you were in
pain please give it to shoe crew
yes that was a channel ladies that was
thank you i felt like gollum was in the
room she showed a new side of girl
i've never seen before all three were
excellent
however um i'm gonna have to give the
point to
john i think john's uh
i liked his golem and he definitely
worked in the elements of the show
so that that makes what did that turn
into oh a nice mask yes where am i
yes sponsored by 40x oh sure
why not moves it has smoke effects it
has heat it's got everything
all right john i believe that makes you
the
of rogue winner that's right
you have won so what is your wish that
you'd like fulfilled
so my wish today here on this episode of
new rock stars
is uh to finally get a solomon grundy
appearance in a damn batman movie that's
what i want eric that's my rogues
gallery guy
alright we can't make that happen here
if anyone on the
youtubes can make it happen it's you all
right i'll see what i can do
uh we'll we'll just photoshop you in
there and then we'll post it on social
or you can post
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
uh but well done to all three of our
hosts that's it for this episode of
rogue theory thank you so much to all
three of you
uh shukri abdi uh always such a fun to
have thank you for having me it was a
pleasure
absolutely and our friends from the real
rejects
john humphrey and greg alba yeah
that's our names thanks for having us
again and be sure to subscribe to their
youtube channel they're always uh making
some real fun videos i love to see
whatever you guys put out there um a
reminder to
everyone watching to subscribe to our
rogue theory podcast feed wherever you
get your podcasts
and stay tuned to our youtube channel
for this and other shows you can follow
me on instagram at eavos follow new
rockstars and socials
at new rockstars and we'll see you next
week bye
[Music]
you